hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in round 4 of
this year's guess about hitani Memorial
Tournament it is pregnant versus Kiro
shivchenko you know both of them I
believe they need no introduction Prague
a bit younger he's 17 currently
shevchenko is 20. and uh sorry this is
uh yeah I know why this position is on
the board but I'm just not I'm not going
to tell you just yet I will tell you in
some 10 moves uh so yeah let's check it
out and see uh what is happening in this
tournament and why some of you aware a
lot of you are requesting um to see it
so Prague has the white pieces and he
opens with E4 we have Pawn to C6 D4 D5
so a standard Karo Khan and you can
reply to this with Knight to C3 go for
the standard stuff Knights the D2
Advanced the pawn to E5 menu options
here even F3 has been played uh but here
Prague goes for not E5 but e captures on
D5 he goes for the exchange variation uh
we have characters and now Bishop to D3
so very popular we have now light the C6
and now Pawn to C3 just strengthening
the D4 pawn and Knight to F6 the top the
absolute top move here Queen to C7 the
second most played so okay still that
can be considered the main line of
course uh we have H3 you kind of want to
play a knight to F3 but you don't want
to give black this free developing move
so first H3 is more popular and now
black has to figure out how to continue
development and pawn to E6 now get the
bishop hasn't been developed so white
takes this as a small victory for
himself Knight to F3 with Bishop to D6
and now castles we have Knight gt7 and
Rook to E1 we have castle spawn to A4
and now Pawn to A6 and it is now as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game that's why this position was
accidentally on the board when I started
up the video and here we have Pawn to B3
now Prague monster and maybe thinking to
maybe play Bishop to A3 the bishop with
B6 and now Bishop to A3 offering a trade
here so Knights the G6 and Bishop
captures on D6 with Queen captures and
Knight beta D2 support players just
continuing development nothing
spectacular Happening Here we have
Knight to F4 now putting pressure on the
bishop here and Bishop goes back to F1
and here we have Ponte E6 sort of
weakening this E6 Pawn uh but you are
limiting the movement of this Knight and
if you are limiting the movement of this
Knight then you cannot play something at
the G5 then this Knight cannot come to
F3 or this Knight to E5 uh it's a bit
harder for whites to play so G3 kicks
away the knight uh Knight Knight back to
G6 and now Pawn to B4 Prague grabs more
space on the queen side King to h8
always a a useful move and now Bishop to
G2 so the bishop is nicely aligned with
the rook and A8 so Rook the B8 and now
Pawn to H4 you want to play Pawn to H5
kick away the Knight and then Advance
the pawn uh well all the way to H6 the
mess up the black uh King spawn
structure uh Bishop to D7 continuing
development and now Queen to E2 and
preparing to advance the pawns all the
way but first point the A5 by black
saying okay if you want to trade I'm
perfectly fine with that I'm going to
capture with the Knight I mean this
could be well this wouldn't really be
all that much for white uh black would
very much enjoy this position so Prague
of course just grabs more space on the
queen Side Pawn to B5 Knights the d8 and
now Pawn to C4 and this is a beautiful
move by Prague uh there's uh well you
could maybe play H5 first but the
product decides to go up onto C4 and
this is the way to do it and now you
also see uh that King tachet was a very
useful move because if cap translates it
captures then the queen occupies this
diagonal bad things could uh happen so
uh here we have Knight the E7 point is
that if you capture the pawn uh Knight
captures on C4 is maybe just giving
black uh too much it's not it's not the
best uh you would have to go back and
then have to rotate the C1 aligning with
the queen where is the queen going to
you have to play something like Queen to
A7 and look at this queen that's uh that
that's no way to treat your queen and
now let's tip on the H5 Knight E7 Pawn
to H6 and already Prague controls the
the queen side the king side he's
attacking he controls the center it's um
well the knight at some point coming to
D6 just a ugly position for black so
instead after C4 Knights the E7 was
played and now we have Pawn to H5 we
have Knights the F7 now nicely
controlling H6 and here you really have
to figure out how to continue this game
probably Bishop H3 is objectively best
just putting pressure on the E6 Pawn uh
but Prague wind uh Rook e to C1 he wants
the uh sorry not Rook e to C1 he played
Rook 8 the C1 he wants to advance that
pawn to C5 and here you should actually
capture on C4 but it wasn't played uh to
give you an example why it's uh strong
because after d captures on C4 and
Knight captures now you can play Queen
to B4 that's the that's the whole point
and now after something like Bishop to
H3 putting pressure on the pawn here uh
there's Knights to D5 and now if Bishop
captures on E6 if you can if you can't
play this then it's great if you can't
play this then white you didn't really
get anything from this because now you
will just play Rook B to E8 and here
probably we would see something like a
repetition Rook to be one Queen C3 Rook
C1 Queen B4 uh but it would be maybe the
safest way for black to play however
Rook beat the C8 was played instead and
now the big difference is that the V6
Pawn is not to defend it and here we
have Bishop to H3 uh and now Knight to
F5 here no longer uh can you capture D
captures on C4 this is uh of the table
because now like I said the B6 Pawn
isn't defended and now uh it would be it
would be just silly uh you know to try
this even if you play Queen to B4 right
away uh and allow something like Knight
captures and uh B6 uh then comes Rook
captures and C1 and now I have to Rook
captures on C1 Bishop 38 and the white
is completely winning here the you have
a beautiful pass Pawn here the pawn is
nicely protected by the knight uh this
is uh winning for Prague so instead
Knights the F5 was played now comes
Bishop captures on F5 yes you are giving
up the bishop but you will mess up a
black spawn structure he captures and
queen to E7 now offering a queen trade
uh D caprese and C for first Knight
captures attacking the queen and only
now Queen captures an E7 we have real
captures on E7 and now Rook the C7
defending the bishop and D7 but now Rook
to C2 uh the rook and C1 is undefended
so you can't really move your knight
otherwise it'll just Rook captures on C1
uh Prague wants to play Knight E1 so The
Rook will be nicely defended King to G8
Now The Rook can move the Knight is
nicely protected on F7 and now comes
Knight to E1 and here believe it or not
you have to play a silly move like oh
you could play F4 it does make sense but
let's say you play Rook d8 and this is
the best black hats uh something like
this happens so let's say captures
captures then the pawn comes off the
board Knight captures on B6 and after
Rook captures Knight captures and you
can try to hold this CSR up only down
only one Pawn but also you have a
doubled pawn and the white has two pass
pawns so chances are you will lose this
maybe it is possible to hold only with
maybe perfect play but after Knight E1
Rook the B8 was played uh sort of uh
bringing back the defender of the B6
Pawn but this move uh completely loses
the game on the spot so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the only
move that wins for Prague while I give
you a couple of seconds
foreign
who are able to do it congratulations on
finding this uh a very very difficult
variation and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight
captures on B6 I know you found it as
you are excellent players but I still
have to show it so Knight captures on B6
and now what do you play your rook and
C7 is hanging so of course you have to
capture on C2 this is what KIRO played
uh now comes Knight captures and D7
attacking The Rook on B8 and now just to
Rook the C7 and the problem is now if
Rod captures on B8 then KIRO captures on
E7 and now how do you play this the the
Knight here is attacked King to F1 and
okay you you have an extra Pawn there's
still two two pass pawns but you're down
the exchange so this would in fact be a
draw or even it would be black playing
for the win but Prague of course finds
the strongest move he just plays Knight
captures on F6 with the check uh grabs
another Pawn while he's at it g
characters and now Rook captures on C7
and he was in this position on move 35
that kill shivchenko resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here he's now down two pawns and okay
sometimes you can play if you're down to
pawns if you're attacking or if it's a
very complicated position but here is
just a very very Elementary end game to
give you an example of how it might
finish let's say black play something
because there really aren't all that
many great moves let's say you go Rook
date you go after the pawn white will
defend it and there's no way to kick
away the knights or the D4 Pawn is
defended forever I mean you have the
double F Pawn so there's no way to
challenge the knight uh let's try
bringing the king into the game King to
G2 let's say you play King T and now
Rook to A7 attacks the A5 Pawn yeah
you're gonna win another Pawn you're
gonna be up three pawns and then of
course it's unplayable so basically
resign here because you're disgusted at
the position and you don't even want to
look for moves I mean that's uh that's
how I see it uh so yeah definitely not
not a premature resignation by Kiron a
very nice Diamond Prague and so far and
also one of the reasons why a lot of you
guys have requested it frog is doing
incredible here he defeated four grand
Masters in a row sound
old Nemesis then Parham Maxwell Adam
Kozak kill shivchenko and today or maybe
today is the rest day but in the in
round five he will be facing Grandmaster
I'm in tapatabai so we'll see if Prague
can continue uh his Onslaught and keep
the the 100 win rate uh he uh came into
the tournament or as a 26 and a 90
player but he is on the live ratings I I
think he's already uh well well past
2700 I will check
um I don't want to trick you guys so let
me just check real quickly uh
what is this oh sorry that's Blitz my
bad
uh let me just check
uh there we have it yeah pregnant is
2709 uh he yeah he climbed up 16 spots
so that's absolutely incredible number
31 in the world uh once the the month is
done uh his rating will uh update and it
will be it will be over 2700 so very
nice Land by Prague uh we'll see what
happens in the rest of the tournament
I'm sure guys are very eager to find out
how he does uh so yeah that's the game I
really hope you guys enjoyed it uh sorry
about no videos yesterday I was visited
by my uh roommate from from college he
he well came came uh to visit me from
Sweden uh we didn't see each other for
some 10 years uh so I took uh a day off
you know took him around the town and
you know we had that we had a good time
uh but yeah I really hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank David
Kimura John malpas Phil Malthus Johan
Bridger and uh Richard Phillips for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
soon continuing uh to check up on you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day